i'm shannon breme i'm bill hemmer i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday
august 17th 2022
i'm dave anthony
he's driving controversy with every bus
he sends north full of illegal
immigrants
and texas governor greg abbott has no
plans to stop as governor i've done more
than any governor in the history of the
united states of america to secure the
border it is now time
for states like new york in cities like
new york city to begin to shoulder some
of that burden
i'm alex hogan a long-form report
details years of cover-up of sexual
assault within the mormon church and now
one utah politician in the church is
calling for new legislation let's make
sure we protect this child
whatever that whatever that takes
whatever that looks like
and i'm tommy laron i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
this is what controversy sounds like
just about every day lately
you can hear the squeals of a bus
arriving in new york city in washington
carrying migrants sent from texas amid a
surge at the border governor greg abbott
blames on president biden's
administration and its policies
d.c mayor muriel bowser says local
taxpayers are not picking up the tab and
should not pick up the tab and we really
need a coordinated federal response
she's trying to get the national guard
to help deal with the thousands of
migrants who came to the u.s illegally
then were shipped there from texas
several hundred more are now in new york
city we are going to provide these
families with the dignity that the texas
governor failed to do that is who we are
as new yorkers mayor eric adams says
governor abbott is using the migrants as
political pawns he is a
anti-american
governor that is
really going against everything we stand
for but former new york governor david
patterson a democrat like adams
called abbott's plan a brilliant stunt
while adams seeks payback with a stunt
of his own i am deeply contemplating
taking a bus load of new yorkers
to go to texas and do some good
old-fashioned door knocking
because we we have to for the good of
america we have to get him out of office
governor abbott says go ahead that would
only help him
and he says the buses will keep coming
the number of migrants he has to send is
unlimited we will continue to bus people
to washington dc to new york city and
maybe to other locations
governor greg abbott is a republican
running for re-election in texas what's
happening with these illegal immigrants
is that the border patrol is dropping
them off in local communities along the
border that have no way of accommodating
these illegal immigrants and so i'm
helping the local communities uh by
busing the migrants out of these local
communities and sending them up to the
northeast where they have
self-identified as sanctuary cities
where they want to welcome in uh any
illegal immigrant and i'm more than
happy to accommodate them now obviously
the mayor of new york city
he said what you're doing is
anti-american
the commissioner of immigrant affairs in
new york says what you're doing is
morally corrupt using these migrants as
political pawns your response
well
that's a brutal condemnation of joe
biden
because if you recall
joe biden has been doing this even more
extensively than we have what joe biden
has done is to in the darkness at night
uh put these illegal immigrants on
planes and flying them into new york uh
and you know the mayor of new york was
complaining about the large number of
illegal immigrants they had before texas
began busing them to washington i mean
to washington dc and before would begin
busting them to new york city uh and it
turned out that all those people that
were gathered there in new york
illegally were because joe biden brought
them in and not once did the new york
mayor ever condemn
the byte administration for what they
were doing uh to put those illegal
immigrants into new york city for one
for another they're just a bunch of
hypocrites you know they they say that
this is what they want to do uh and that
we all
you know texas need to step up and help
america well by god texas is on the
front line here
of trying to help america by taking
unprecedented action and governor i've
done more than any governor in the
history of the united states of america
to secure the border it is now time
for states like new york and cities like
new york city to begin to shoulder some
of that burden now new york's mayor is
also saying that they've been forced to
go essentially and not allowed to get
off the bus almost like they were
tricked they couldn't go anywhere but
new york city
what do you say to that
before
demographics get on the buses
they sign a form
agreeing to get on the bus and on that
form it has the pre-identified
destination
they actually get to choose do they want
to go to
the capital of the united states of
america or do they want to go to new
york city
and the people who are going to new york
are choosing to go to new york
so
last month you signed an executive order
that allows state troopers to take
migrants and bring them back to ports of
entry in texas the aclu is trying to get
the federal government to stop
cooperating with you is that how you are
getting the migrants to put on buses no
that's unrelated to the migrant
situation so let me break this down for
you okay okay
there's several different ways in which
we deal with the migrants step number
one
we have the national guard on the border
and the national guard on the border is
in charge of among other things
turning back
illegal immigrants
and they have turned back
tens of thousands of illegal immigrants
before they could ever even get into
texas
secondly the texas department of public
safety uh if migrants do get into texas
uh they will arrest them and send them
back to the border the the people that
we are busting don't fall into either of
those two categories a third category is
the most voluminous category
and that is illegal immigrants who come
across the border and immediately turn
themselves into border patrol border
patrol will process their paperwork
allowing them to stay in the united
states of america and then drop them off
in these local communities across the
border it's that last category uh that
is providing
the volume that we are dealing with that
we are bussing from texas to washington
dc and new york okay all right and how
is that being funded for your state how
are you doing that
so uh for the most part it's the state
of texas that's funding it what what the
state has done is really unprecedented
because
we have allocated more than four
billion dollars of texas taxpayer money
for texas to
not just bus illegal and regressive not
just to secure the border but also to
build a border wall ourselves but on top
of that
we've had an outpouring of support from
people across the entire country wanting
to help out and if your listeners want
to help out you can go to a website is
borderbuss.
and make a donation you have also in the
last few months been trying to do some
of the work on border wall
building that was stopped
after president trump left office where
is texas on that
so we were able to uh in a fashion far
faster than what president trump was
able to do
to begin
building the border wall and the reason
that's simple and that is
some of the land not very much but some
of the land on the border is owned
and controlled by the state of texas we
were able to build border wall on those
areas using the same contractors the
same materials in the same wall
that president trump
put up
now what we're doing is exactly what
president trump did which kind of slowed
down his process and that is we're going
through
land acquisition process
so we can gather more land from private
property owners so that we can build
begin building border walls on those
areas that's what if you go back in time
to when president trump built the wall
you know
that it took him
well over a year from the time he began
the process so the time it began putting
up the wall and the main reason for
that delay uh was the time that it took
to acquire the lab we have a team of
people with a state agency that are
working with local landowners putting
together parcels of land on which we can
build even more border wall
governor abbott's democratic challenger
in november is beto o'rourke a former
congressman who ran for president in
2020 you might recall as a gun control
advocate and is running for texas
governor on the same platform that we
take common sense steps we find the
common ground
democrats and republicans gun owners
non-gun owners o'rourke is pushing a ban
on so-called assault weapons like the
rifle the gunman used to murder 19
students and two teachers in a ivaldi
school back in may the dallas morning
news has a new poll that shows
two-thirds of texans want governor
abbott to call a special legislative
session to deal with math shootings
here's the reality
and that is the fbi put out a report
and it showed that the for last year the
number one state in america for mass
shootings
was in a state like texas it was
california the point is this
california has some of the most
restrictive gun laws in the united
states uh and until recently uh they had
a ban
on someone age 18 from buying an ar the
reason why i say until recently is
because
in may of this year
a federal court of appeals struck down
that ban as unconstitutional here's the
point
i i know that there are people in texas
and elsewhere who would like to see a
prohibition on 18 year olds from buying
an ar the fact of the matter is federal
courts have struck that down as
unconstitutional so what we need to do
is that because california
is really the leader uh in mass
shootings and you see places like
chicago it proves one fact and that is
more gun laws don't lead to less gun
crime we need to get to the root of the
problem the real rule of the problem
is the mental health status of these
people who are school shooters we've
seen
studies that show characteristics of
these school shooters and they're very
common
and what texas has done to respond to
that
we've provided an unprecedented amount
of funding for mental health for
students in schools so that we will be
able to address
the mental health challenges that our
students and schools are having so that
we can prevent future acts of violence
in yuvaldi there was a big focus on the
law enforcement's response
what do you want done after that to
bolster what happened in what could
happen in the future at school
first we want accountability
what happened in new valley is the
response by law enforcement did not
comply with the national standard the
state standard or even the local
standard of what the response is let's
go back in time the response to a school
shooting
nationally was developed in the
aftermath of the shooting in columbine
and
what the
standard is is
to run toward the shooter and take the
shooter out without hesitation knowing
that seconds count and as many americans
have seen
that's not what law enforcement did in
uvalde they violated that protocol and
there needs to be accountability for
that then second what we want to do as a
state uh
myself and in the legislature we're
going to reevaluate this about uh who is
the incident commander in this case it
was the police the local school district
police chief uh we will reevaluate who
the incident commander should be in a
situation like this and we likely will
reaffirm the standard
if there is a school shooting or some
other type of mass shooting you go
directly to the shooter and take the
shooter out without hesitation if you as
a law enforcement officer are not up to
that job you need to find another job
texas governor greg abbott a republican
thank you very much for joining us this
morning my pleasure you all take care
[Music]
this is tommy laron with your fox news
commentary coming up
every year millions of children suffer
sexual abuse or exploitation according
to unicef one in ten girls under the age
of 20 years old has been forced into a
sexual act the international problem is
prevalent in nearly every segment of
society a new report by the associated
press unveils cover-ups in the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints and
measures taken by mormon officials that
prevented confessions of abuse and rape
from getting passed on to authorities
one politician says that he is
introducing legislation that would
require clergy to report child abuse
this was in the works well before that
came out that particular story here's
utah representative phil lionman but the
story just totally highlights um exactly
the issue
here i believe
a lot of family members of victims are
calling on the church to do more saying
that there are too many pathways to
protect people who might be committing
these types of acts something that you
yourself have said that you agree with
so how true is this across the board
well the law the way it's written right
now is just so um nebulous and it's one
of the least enforced laws i don't know
how you really could enforce it
and
regardless of the exception for the
clergy which then just throws in a
whole different twist it almost
justifies a bad law by saying well but
the clergy is exempt
and i don't know that i don't know that
changing you know taking away the
exception for clergy is really going to
impact
people's lives as much as addressing
this law in general and saying okay well
what is our responsibility to the
children and to and to a person who
wants to change their life and you know
come clean right now the law is so
riddled with nebulous languages
subjective language that that really
throws it into a space where where a
person in that situation is just left to
their own to their own best judgment and
that's not the way from a legislative
standpoint that's not the way the law is
supposed to
to read
yeah well just to bring others up to
speed with how this works and how varied
it is state to state right now there's
about 20 states that currently require
clergy to report sexual child abuse and
neglect
but at the same time
there there is other parts of that
saying that quote they may withhold
information if they deem it's
responsible under the church doctrine so
how do you separate those two and what
measures
can you put in place to really protect
and prevent clergy from withholding this
kind of information going forward
i i think that's the question of the day
honestly is it was what can you do to
prove to prevent this um
this abuse so when i read utah's law it
has things like a reason to believe
that a child is or has been or would
reasonably be subject
to neglect or abuse we need to start
throwing reasonably into the into the
legal language and it's like we've tied
this into this big old knot
of anybody in that situation
would would look at that and say i'm not
sure what i'm supposed to do so
some churches have said okay well that's
why we have this hotline even though i'm
sure it's well intended the net result
is that people who are in danger are not
getting
um help and and and you know as soon as
i say that i think you know is the state
the best
uh anthony to step in and help these
families do they are they better than
the church i'm not sure that they always
are which maybe we need to have a little
bit better oversight over our agencies
maybe they should have more defined
investigative procedures and reporting
requirements themselves so that we're
functional so that it's clear and it's
brightline
language in these laws so
it needs a lot of work and it's so
vitally important
uh you know any family that is is
dealing with this is in a really really
rough um
spot and it just can't be kicked over
into you know legal debates for for
months on end
yeah and just to again bring our
listeners uh into the conversation a
little more the the hotline that we're
talking about this was a hotline that
was created in 1995 in the church of
latter-day saints and it essentially was
a forum in order to pass some of
these reports along to see what the best
course uh of action would be but in this
case that we saw the associated press
report the hotline had been used and
abuse went on for years and years so
despite as as you mentioned potentially
efforts and what the goals were
intentionally it's not being met at
least
not 100
yeah that's that's that's that's right
um you know it from a religious
standpoint when a person wants to repent
um confession is a really important part
of that and confession is a really
important part of our society and to
take responsibility for your actions and
to actually be able to speak those
things out loud to another person is so
important but also a person who is in a
repentant state is going to take the
you know the consequences of whatever
may come from that to say you know i if
i'm in a situation i say well i want to
repent but i don't want any legal
repercussions from this that's not true
repentance and it's a strange place for
a clergy member to find themselves when
they're being used almost as a buffer
between you know that person's
conscience and what they really need to
do to take responsibility and i think
the clergy's responsibility is to help
them
to step forward and take responsibility
and maybe coach them through that
because it is very difficult and someone
that has that desire
you don't want him to be you know
dissuaded from
moving forward with that desire and um
and and that's where i think the clergy
can step in and and if and if the clergy
says you know i simply don't want to be
in a position where i'm going to report
this then they should probably disclose
that at the beginning of a
sit down i've every sit down interview
and then i don't know if they're really
you know functioning in the space that
they were
supposed to function in which is to
which is to help people take full
responsibility regardless of those
consequences
so your new plan in terms of introducing
this new legislation let's break this
down a little bit what exactly would
change if all of your goals are passed
the bill that i introduced really and my
press release was really an invitation
to discuss this
and i wanted a discussion about it so i
look at the i look at the exception and
the exception is
it doesn't make any sense so so i'd like
to see
i'd like to see the legislature have the
discussion i hope that the lds church
will you know support
this effort and engage in the in the
conversation and i believe they will i'm
an active member of the lds faith and
i'm
you know devout member so i i don't feel
like i'm trying to poke anybody in the
eye or shake up anybody's system it's
just from a legislative standpoint
my goal would be to create some clear
language that that is actually
meaningful in this space because it's so
important
and better protection for for victims
especially when we are seeing cases of
systemic abuse when we're talking about
the rape of of children even even babies
so when you have conversations not only
on the legislative side but within
members of your faith have you heard uh
commentary of people being receptive to
this and hopeful that this could bring
about better change
overwhelmingly positive response to this
with some exceptions and the exceptions
come from people who say you know do you
really want to
turn all this to the state
with their bureaucracy and the answer is
no i don't like the bureaucracy of the
state and i like to address that too
but when we're talking about the kinds
of
incidences that we've seen that are you
know clearly
you know threatening to
to children that's not that's that's not
some place where you say well let's
let's
make sure we keep this confidence that's
let's make sure we protect this child
uh whatever that whatever that takes
whatever that looks like um but it has
to go it has to move quickly and it has
to be done
you know without equivocation and and
that child's uh safety has got to be
protected and then you take that you you
can take the flip side may be an
overzealous
person whether it be whether it be in
the clergy or not but an overzealous
person who is reporting
their neighbor because you know their
their kids were playing outside without
atten you know a parent attending and
things like that so we don't we don't
want to create you know a situation
where we make criminals out of people
who are not criminals but we certainly
don't want to create a situation where
truly dangerous um people who are out of
control and admittedly out of control
are just um left
unchecked and and the the victims that
are in their wake are are having their
lives destroyed in the meantime that's
not acceptable from
again from the from the plain language
that the law should provide that's
simply not acceptable
yeah and we when we look at the the
population of utah and the predominance
of of
people who are in the church of um
latter-day saints in utah do you think
that there will be any hurdles
potentially getting any of this passed
or moving forward with new policies
potentially in place
the challenge with uh in utah
is always kind of you know turning that
jet that giant ship uh slightly um
because it is very large and very
ingrained in the society and and has a
you know well-established hierarchy of
leadership and
things like that which we which we as
members don't typically challenge or
question
so my challenge as a legislator is to
have those meaningful discussions and
yeah
i don't know how anyone who's actually
willing to sit down and read this
section of code
could disagree that it needs it needs to
be changed and as far as the the
exception for clergy
honestly if you're going to accept
clergy you should accept best friends
and family members and
anybody else who is told something in
confidence and that's not the
i it doesn't make sense to say you know
that only the clergy are accepted from
this and really nobody should be
accepted i guess is what i'm coming down
to is nobody should be accepted from
obligation to report responsibly to a
responsible
entity and that's the next that's the
next chapter that says okay do we have
responsible organizations who will
handle this professionally and not be
used as a as a as a tool in the hands of
somebody that's vindictive and we do
unfortunately see that sometimes as well
so you've got to stay you've got to stay
in the middle of the road on this
on this legal language and not with all
of these detours and you know loopholes
how did this come about for you to take
up this issue why is this such an
important topic for you personally
well this this has come up in the
legislature a couple of times um
and it's never made it it's never
actually made it out of the rules
committee to even be heard in a standing
committee
and i think just given the
the current
environment that people are in i think
it's more relevant now than ever
i think the time is right for it to come
forward and
and i do feel like being a legislator
who is an active member of the
of the lds faith and um you know devout
and interested in
solving the problem versus
identifying
you know problems with the with the
organization hopefully that hopefully
that carries a little different tone a
little bit different flavor
mm-hmm yeah so so so yeah i i believe
that it's the right time it's
and and the language is
with what i've proposed so far is is
about as simple as you can get just
remove the exception
i do think it's going to lead to
discussion about the underlying life
there's no exception maybe we do need to
look at the underlying line
utah state representative phil lyman
thanks so much for your time
thank you
[Music]
and in other news i'm gianna delosi what
do candy corn and football season have
in common
at first thought not much but candy
company brox is tying the two together
for a fall tailgate season special just
for your taste buds enter tailgate candy
corn blending all your favorite flavors
of a football stadium tailgate and the
controversial candy of halloween the
candy comes in five flavors hamburger
hot dog popcorn vanilla ice cream and
fruit punch last year brock's compiled a
list of 20 states that eat the most
candy corn and found fans in california
texas florida new york and michigan all
big football states might i add but the
candy is controversial many people say
they straight up can't stand the stuff
even some say it's like the peeps of
halloween candy that same survey from
before though found that alabama hawaii
nebraska vermont and wisconsin have the
lowest candy horn sales but if you are a
fan of the waxy candy or you're just a
little bit intrigued by this whole thing
you can pick up the tailgate candy corn
at participating walgreens until the end
of october a company spokesperson says
an 11-ounce bag is going to retail
between 3.49
and 3.69
if fruit punch and hot dog candy corn
not really your style well brock says
they're going to be releasing more candy
corn surprises in the weeks leading up
to halloween so keep your eyes and taste
buds peeled for the fox news rundown i'm
gianna delosi
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind the popular texas
based amusement park six flags has lost
about 2 million customers in the last
year and shares are also down about 18
percent the company's ceo is blaming
out-of-control teens and their absentee
parents for the steep decline in park
attendance saying it became a cheap
daycare center for teenagers during
breaks in the summers and he's not wrong
out-of-control teens have been blamed
for several violent outbursts in several
locations over the last year last month
in new jersey a teen was arrested for
aggravated assault after attacking a
police officer sent to the park to tamp
down on the chaos in response to this
growing problem the company is hiking
prices to drive out the riff raff as
they should there is no reason decent
people should have to fear for their
family's safety in an amusement park of
all places where are the parents where
is the discipline our country is
becoming one giant lawless free-for-all
and it's beyond disappointing we allow
it to continue it's time to start
showing some tough love to these teens
enough i'm tommy larry and you can
listen to all my hot takes at
foxnewscommentary.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic fox news contributor and
editor of thetransom.com daily
newsletter and i'm inviting you to join
a conversation every week it's the ben
dominic podcast subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes